in a place where nearly half the adults
are considered obese an incidence of
diabetes and heart disease lead the
nation one man is coming to lead a food
revolution this is about life and death
[Music]
people like to come together at
mealtimes enjoy each other's company
while they're enjoying good food as your
piece of for breakfast in all of my
years I've never seen pizza give him for
breakfast in any country hi I'm Michael
Moynihan freezing TV and that was
British celebrity chef Jamie Oliver and
his campaign against delicious food like
this has come to our shores Oliver says
that we need a food revolution in this
country and he's starting the school
lunches which he claims are killing
America's children
in February Oliver scooped up the
prestigious TED Prize awarded for his
crusade against obesity and other diet
related diseases upon receiving the
award he warned America that it was
committing national suicide through food
we the adults of the last four
generations have blessed our children
with the destiny of a shorter lifespan
than their own parents your child will
live a life ten years younger than you
though Americans are surely in need of a
collective diet the CDC recently
reported that obesity levels are finally
leveling off in Oliver's claim that
young Americans will live shorter lives
and their parents is nonsense but this
sort of overheated rhetoric has
attracted the attention of some
influential people but it's also what's
going on in our schools because most of
our kids get the majority of their
calories from the meals that they eat in
schools food bloggers and journalists at
brusky recently spent a week inside a
Washington DC lunch room and like Oliver
was disturbed by what he found the
problem is is that schools have fallen
kind of into sought-out the least common
denominator of food being a kind of
fast-food bordering on junk food you
know how much would an ideal system cost
I defer to people like Ann Cooper
because they know a lot more about it
than I do and she's right now
campaigning for an extra dollar per meal
and I think it works out to something
like five billion dollars a year that
would be represent a huge increase
actually in the school food budget and
not for a big increase in the you know
the total budget but not everyone agrees
that better school lunches
and more money would help fix America's
obesity problem kids in America are fat
they're not fat because of school lunch
school lunches could be better but if we
have five billion to spend I've got a
lot of things I want to spend it on that
are going to improve the lives of kids
before we get some organic kale on their
lunch tray he always enjoyed looking at
the good food in the cafeteria it tasted
good and was good for him to fill didn't
want to forget his dessert the cake
looked delicious part of that mandatory
lunch
is the protein and vegetable
requirements which come from the federal
government and which are provided in
often giant surplus food tubs by the US
Department of Agriculture the USDA
mark of wholesomeness corporations
provide America's food they just do and
they could be providing better food to
America's kids if it weren't for huge
government programs that are distorting
what kids eat and why a point often
ignored by reformers like jamie oliver's
the role of the government in providing
substandard food to schools according to
a recent investigation by USA Today the
government has provided the nation's
schools with millions of pounds of beef
and chicken that wouldn't meet the
quality or safety standards of many fast
food restaurants school lunch programs
don't just provide welfare to
lower-income students but also to
American agribusiness well there is a
perverse sort of irony there that what
we think is healthiest for kids to eat
is the stuff that they least want to eat
when you have some peas Ralphie oh
that's too bad and what we think of as
foods that they should not be eating is
what they most want to eat you have to
have people in the kitchen who really
care about what they're serving and know
what they're doing and that's going to
cost more money to the government right
now is spending somewhere in the
neighborhood of about 12 billion dollars
a year to pay for breakfasts and lunches
in the schools they never have quite
enough money and in order to get the
federal money
they have to serve the meal so if the
kids don't take the meals they don't get
the money and all of a sudden they're
running a deficit in this provides a
strong incentive to serve kids
cheeseburgers and pizza as brusky
observed and is reporting from the
Washington DC school district students
routinely avoided healthy snacks in
favor of less healthy alternatives in
Britain Oliver succeeded in pressuring
the government into increasing the
school lunch funding by a billion
dollars the results have been mixed and
some students have even taken the
opportunity to create junk food black
markets Michelle Obama Ned brusky
advocate for something similar to all of
his UK program here in the u.s. a large
increase in funding that would buy
kitchen equipment trained staff and
increase the two dollars and seventy
cents already allotted for every school
launch by a full dollar but they also
have a bigger goal not just making
school meals but using fresh ingredients
and serving the kids fresh appealing
palatable foods that they like and will
eat there is something to be said for
eating fresh food but fresh food and
healthy food aren't the same thing
you can take two dollars and 70 cents
and get a perfectly good lunch people do
it every day
it's a microwaveable healthy choice the
lunch of choice for many many working
adults we could give that to kids they
don't understand me because I don't know
why I'm here look people like Oliver a
right to point out that school food
could to put it mildly use some
improvement the problem with fat kids in
America isn't pizza and burgers in the
cafeteria or a lack of funds but of the
consumption of fatty foods increasingly
sedentary lifestyles in a government
monopoly on school food distribution so
Jamie thanks for the advice we'll
consider it in the meantime I'm going to
eat this delicious cheeseburger for
region TV
I'm Michael Moynihan
[Music]
well would you like some tea well okay
well what happened to you